lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
obtener más práctica para saber cuándo
usar la sustitución 1 y cómo elegir una
apropiada
así que tomemos la integral indefinida
del a logaritmo natural de x ok esto
elevado a la potencia 10 y todo eso
entre x de x
podemos aplicar aquí la sustitución 1 y
si es así cuál sería nuestra bueno la
clave de la sustitución y es pensar en
si tenemos una función y su derivada
dentro de la integral y te seguro vas a
reconocer de manera rápida que la
derivada del logaritmo natural de x es 1
/ x el más para que sea más claro voy a
escribir esto como la integral del
logaritmo natural de x esto elevado la
potencia 10 x 1 / x x de x ahora lo
tengo más claro aquí hay una función el
logaritmo natural de x elevado a la
décima potencia multiplicado por su
derivada así que podemos usar una
sustitución o podemos decir que uno es
igual al logaritmo natural de x y si te
preguntas por qué elegía el logaritmo
natural de x como nostrum fue porque
tenemos aquí multiplicando a su derivada
o algo cercano a su derivada y por lo
tanto puedo decir
la derivada de o con respecto a x es 1 /
x
si vemos esto como diferenciales podemos
escribirlo como la derivada de uno es
igual a 1 entre x por de x
por lo que este de aquí es justo de un y
este de aquí es nuestra 1 entonces esto
se simplifica como la integral de
elevado a la décima potencia de y de
modo que aquí puedes encontrar la anti
derivada de una manera sencilla y
después reemplazarla por el logaritmo
natural de x lo cual me daría el
resultado de mi integral indefinida
inicial bien trabajemos con otra
integral para ver si podemos aplicar una
sustitución
o no tengo la integral de la tangente de
x de x y esta va a ser muy interesante
podemos aplicar aquí la sustitución 1 y
si es así cuál sería nuestra u
tal vez lo primero que digas es si tengo
la tangente de x donde estaría su
derivada
pero qué tal si escribimos la tangente
de x en términos del seno y del cose no
puedo escribir esto como la integral del
seno de x entre el coseno dx de x y
ahora preguntarnos podemos aplicar la
sustitución y si es así cuál sería
nuestra 1
podremos decir que la derivada del seno
de x es el coseno de x pero aquí estamos
dividiendo que es opuesto lo que
queremos es decir multiplicar más
interesante es pensar en que la derivada
del coste de x es el menos seno de x
y bueno no tenemos el menú de equis pero
podemos hacer un poco de manipulación
algebraica y multiplicar por menos 12
veces podemos poner aquí un signo
negativo y dentro otro signo negativo
esto sale simplemente de las propiedades
de la integración puedo poner un signo
negativo afuera de la integral y otro
dentro de ella y tener acá arriba la
derivada del coseno de x que es justo lo
que queríamos es más déjame escribirlo
de nuevo voy a tener menos la integral
de uno entre el coseno de x por el menos
seno de x de x
y espero que esto te dé la idea de que
vamos a obtener tengo un coste no de x
en el denominador y tengo su derivada
así que qué te parece si hacemos una
sustitución o hagamos un igual al coseno
de x y por lo tanto la derivada de v con
respecto a x es igual al menos seno de x
y si vemos esto como diferenciales me
queda que de eeuu es igual al menos seno
de x de x
cuando esto puedo decir que tengo me dé
justo aquí y por acá tengo mi 1 y todo
esto se simplifican como menos la
integral de 1 entre 1 de 1
la cual es una integral mucho más fácil
de resolver y una vez que la resuelva se
puede reemplazarla por el coseno de x
en fin espero que esto te haya servido
porque con esto hemos terminado nos
vemos en el siguiente